merci pour votre implication madame la
députée la parole est à madame marianne
dubois pour le groupe est républicain
oui merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la culture et de la communication j'y
associe ma collègue elisabeth pochon en
tant que co présidente du groupe
d'études de l'assemblée nationale sur la
langue des signes il convient de
regretter l'exclusion de l'information
des personnes sourdes depuis une semaine
suite aux terribles attentats qui ont
endeuillé notre pays alors que l'accès à
l'information est déterminante dans ces
cas précis les personnes sourdes se sont
sentis mal informé les sous titres des
chaînes notamment pour les journaux
télévisés n'étant pas de qualité trop
rapide pour ces personnes qui ont
souvent des difficultés de lecture
imaginez-vous le stress supplémentaire
et les inquiétudes qu'ils ressentent
lorsque défilent des images des
reportages et des intervenants sans en
appréhender l'exacte traduction
l'absence d'interprètes en lsf pour les
discours du président de la république
et des plus hautes autorités de l'état
dans ces circonstances pose également un
certain nombre d'interrogations
légitimes auxquelles il convient de
répondre si les attentats de paris du 13
novembre au t'occuper la majorité des
journaux télévisés français
les internautes ont dénoncé leur manque
d'accessibilité aux personnes
malentendantes
ils ont été contraints de créer une page
facebook intitulée fusillade à paris en
direct
lsf cette initiative a été saluée et
elle a été suivie par plus de 5000
personnes et des appels ont été lancés
sur les réseaux sociaux pour favoriser
la transmission de l'actualité en langue
des signes
madame la ministre nous sommes tous
d'accord pour estimer que chacun a droit
à l'information et et je rappelle que
l'accessibilité ne se résume pas
seulement à la mise aux normes de
bâtiments
par conséquent nous vous demandons de
rendre l'information accessible aux
personnes sourdes par des sous titres de
qualité
les alertes officielles sur les réseaux
sociaux des interprètes pendant les
journaux télévisés et pendant les
interventions des autorités qu'elles
annoncent pouvez-vous faire sur cette
situation précisément et plus glam mais
s'il me voit
il apparaît et à madame fleur pellerin
ministre de la culture et de la
communication merci monsieur le
président madame la députée vous pose
effectivement une question essentielle
et vous avez raison de dire que chacun a
le droit d'accéder à une information de
qualité
alors vous le savez la loi a posé un
certain nombre de principes et en
particulier celui d'une adaptation très
large des programmes télévisés pour
qu'il soit accessible au plus grand
nombre de nos concitoyens
c'est un enjeu d'égalité ainsi les
grandes chaînes hertziennes qui font
plus de 2 5% de part d'audience en
moyenne doivent rendre accessible
l'intégralité de leurs programmes et
parce que les programmes d'information
évidemment une importance particulière
et notamment en ce moment les trois
chaînes d'information de la tnt doivent
également mettre à l'antenne
trois journaux télévisés sous-titré est
un journal télévisé traduit en langue
des signes
du lundi au vendredi et quatre journaux
télévisés sous-titré le week end et les
jours fériés avec évidemment répartition
des horaires de diffusion entre les
trois chaînes s'agissant des france
télévisions le contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens actuels à renforcer les
engagements pris par l'entreprise en
2011 afin de favoriser l'accès des
personnes handicapées à ces programmes
il prévoit en particulier d'achever le
sous titrage intégral de tous les
programmes nationaux des chaînes de
france télévisions france télévisions sa
tâche par ailleurs à étendre à tous les
écrans la disponibilité de programmes
accessibles avec depuis le printemps
2012 la mise en service d'une option au
dessous qui de sous titrage sur une
grande partie des programmes proposés en
télévision de rattrapage sur pluzz et
depuis fin 2013 la mise à disposition de
sous titres et de l'audiodescription sur
la version mobile de pluzz en direct ses
fonctionnalités auront vocation à être
généralisée progressivement à tous les
supports et à tous les systèmes
d'exploitation en matière de langue des
signes puisque votre question portait
également sur celle sur cette langue des
signes france télévisions s'est engagée
dans une démarche très active de
recherche et développement pour explorer
les possibilités offertes par les
nouveaux supports de diffusion est
d'ores et déjà france télévisions assure
la diffusion avec une fenêtre en langue
des signes de deux flashs d'information
quotidien des culs âgées sur france 3 et
d'un magazine sur france 5 dont je peux
vous assurer de la volonté de ce
gouvernement avec ma collègue ségolène
neuville de faire en sorte que vos
préoccupations marry me